- What's up, believe nation?
It's Evan, I'm excited
to launch a new series.
We're code-naming it Believe Love.
The idea here is, it can be really hard
for entrepreneurs, not
just to start a business,
you know how crazy it is to
start and run a business,
but also to manage your
relationship at the same time.
Maybe the person you're with
is also an entrepreneur,
and you're fighting to even
spend any kind of time together,
'cause you're both so busy.
Maybe the person you're
with is not an entrepreneur,
and has a nine-to-five job,
and that can be a struggle, just in terms
of understanding each other,
and support that you need.
And so, I get so many
questions from entrepreneurs,
and wannabe entrepreneurs,
that deal with relationships,
and I thought: how about
we make it a weekly series.
It's going to be a test;
we'll see what you guys think.
To showcase different pieces of advice
that you might be able to use,
bring it to your life, and hopefully
help you have healthier, strongier,
strongier, strongier,
(laughing)
happier relationships,
because when you're happy
at home too, you have so much more energy
that you can bring to your business,
and go off and do amazing things.
And so today, we're going
to learn from the legendary
Iyanla Vanzant, and her tips
on how to fight fairly.
- How to resolve differences,
and upsets, in a relationship.
So, I'm going to shorten that
and make it: how to fight fair.
Fights, meaning upsets, disagreements,
and arguments, are normal,
even in the best of relationships.
What matters is, how you handle it.
Now, I know there are those people
who think the first time
they have a disagreement
or an argument, that the
relationship is over.
Wrong!
What makes an argument, or an upset,
or a disagreement, even a slight breakdown
in a relationship, meaningful,
is how you handle it,
and how you handle yourself.
So, whether it's a
long-standing love ship,
or a new relationship, understanding
how to handle those difficult
places, those upsets,
and fighting fairly, is crucial
for the success of any
and every relationship.
Normally, when folks have a disagreement
or an argument, even if
they love each other,
either of them instinctively wants to win
and prove that they're right.
However, when you are in a relationship,
you really have to understand
that fighting to be right,
holding on to your position,
is usually not going to
turn out well for you.
In most arguments, we expect
there will be a winner
and a loser; when, however,
we are dealing with a loving relationship,
an argument can either
make both of you winners,
or make both of you suffer,
depending on how you do it.
So, here's a few tips, few
things that I've learned
along the way, that I'd
like to share with you,
because I was a gotta-win person.
First, stay focused
on the current conflict,
and resist the temptation
to be a history major.
I'll explain that in a little bit,
but when things get heated, it is easy
to lose sight of the real conflict,
especially when it feels
like you are the one
that's losing the argument.
When that happens, you will be tempted,
particularly us ladies,
to bring up everything,
all of the history,
of everything your partner
or friend has done wrong.
You may think that you're using evidence
to make your point stronger,
however, what happens
is you are contributing
to a shut-down, and frustration
that will not resolve the
issue or end the argument.
So stick to what the upset is about,
what angered you in this moment,
rather than every other upset
that you never brought to the table.
It will serve you to focus on one aspect,
and solve that one issue,
instead of going all over the place
and dragging the other person
through the mud of the past.
Next, and this is really,
really, really important:
don't low-blow the other person.
There are times in a relationship
when all you see is red, particularly
when you're arguing.
When this happens,
the easiest way to hurt your partner,
or the person you're in upset with,
is to hit them where it hurts,
by calling them names,
or talking about how much
weight they've gained,
or how many things
they've failed at doing.
Not only are you pulling
on, and triggering
a sensitive nerve, digging around
an insecurity, you are
not fighting fairly.
Oh, you may manage to bring
the other person to tears,
to make them feel weak,
but why would you ever want to do that?
Just to prove that you're
right and they're wrong?
If you want to fight fairly,
don't blow the other person,
because that traumatizes them,
and it creates something that you
will only have to clean up later on, okay?
Number three:
resist the temptation to be sarcastic,
because sarcasm hurts.
Oh, really?
Who, you?
Yeah, I bet you will.
These are just a few of the biting,
stinging, sarcastic remarks
that not only hurt, but also
piss the other person off,
and force them to start low-blowing you,
or bringing up past issues,
just to get even.
And when that gets started,
a misunderstanding can lead
to an all-out terroristic war.
And guess what?
Wars create casualties and fatalities.
Sarcasm not only wounds the ego,
it damages the heart
and it diminishes the other person,
while it dishonors you.
Stay away from the low blows.
Number four:
don't come into an argument
with your mind made up
that the other person is
wrong and you are right.
(laughing)
Okay?
Be willing to ask questions
and share your assumptions.
Be willing to hear what is said,
and without relying on
what you have already
made up, in your mind,
when the other person wasn't even present.
Talk about what you
feel and what you felt.
Talk about your perspective
and what you think is going on,
without making accusations
and assumptions.
Be willing to get off your position
in response to what you hear,
because as long as you stay planted
in the need to be right,
the argument or the upset
will linger and grow.
Stay open to the possibility
that you may have been mistaken,
even in that conversation
you had in your own head,
where you won.
Number five:
supporting that last point,
you must listen to each other.
I know it's hard,
but it is an absolute must.
In a healthy relationship,
you must respect each other's opinion,
and you cannot do that if
you're not willing to listen.
And guess what?
The best way to be heard
is to be willing to hear somebody else.
Now, in listening, you need not agree,
but you must listen to what is being said.
You may feel attacked or
wronged by an accusation,
or maybe a very invalid point, however,
it is important to fair fighting
to make an effort not
to cut the person off,
and to listen to what they're saying.
And while you're listening,
don't formulate your response in your head
and then, respond to what you've heard
rather than what was actually said.
In spite of what most people think,
an argument can help a
relationship get better,
and help both of you
understand each other more.
However, if you do not listen
you cannot hear what is being said.
You will make stuff up
that has nothing to do
with the other person,
or what is going on.
Remember, you need not agree,
but you want to make the effort to listen
and hear, so that you will be heard.
Number six: mmmm,
keep breathing.
And I know this sounds stupid,
but against everything,
I want you to do your best
not to raise your voice.
I know, I know.
(laughing)
That sounds crazy in an argument.
But all arguments don't have to operate
at a 10; you can do it at a five,
because when you raise your voice,
it will no only infuriate
the other person,
who will probably start yelling back,
it may frighten them,
making them even more defensive.
And when they're defensive,
they cannot be available to hear you;
they can't be available to a resolution.
Raised voices can make a
mountain out of a molehill,
and cloud the issue.
Now, you're not talking to a wild child
or a stranger;
not sure why you would yell
at either of them either,
but, I do know that yelling
does not make your point
stronger or more right.
Staying in control of yourself,
speaking with a calm voice,
even if you go from three to five to six,
hold it right there.
A calm voice can also
calm the other person down
and turn an argument into a discussion,
rather than a fight.
Here's number seven:
to fight fairly,
you must be willing to tell the truth.
Withholding information,
distorting information,
sugar-coating bad behavior,
or out-and-out being dishonest
is going to backfire sooner or later.
Lying will make the
other person suspicious.
People know when you're
not telling the truth,
and that destroys trust.
Tell the truth, even when it's hard.
Speak your mind and your truth
in a way that doesn't
intentionally inflict harm.
Say what needs to be said,
and be willing to hear the truth
about you and your behavior.
Number eight, this is another big one:
don't blame your failures
and shortcomings, or behaviors,
on anyone else.
In the midst of an argument,
it is absolutely essential that you own
and accept responsibility
for your behavior,
your choices, and the
consequences of both of those.
Nothing takes a disagreement
down the road to disaster faster
than when you are blaming the other person
for what you did or did not do.
Don't blame anyone else
for your misfortunes,
your failures, or your shortcomings.
If you feel strongly about
something someone did,
speak about it, owning your part in it.
It may not be anybody's fault.
Sometimes stuff just happens.
Sometimes it could be
a big misunderstanding,
but you've got to tell the truth
about what you did, what you didn't do,
what you feel, what you said,
what you heard, and
what you want right now.
It may take some effort and humility
to put your arms around
someone after a fresh fight;
this is why it is so important
to fight in a way that shows
that both of you respect each other,
and that you love each other.
Refuse to allow big or small
irritating misunderstandings
to come in the way
of the love that you share.
Fight fairly.
Stay engaged.
Fighting fairly may not
only help you understand
each other better, but it means
that you will have a
healthier relationship
when the dust settles.
Remember, fighting need
not be fatal.
Pick your battles wisely,
and always fight
without drawing blood.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know: what did
you think of this video?
Did you like some of the points here?
Which one is most
relevant, applicable to you
in your situation right now?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'd also love to know: what do you think
about this new potential
series, Believe Love,
once a week, on the weekend,
to show a little bit more
of the personal side,
help you with your relationships?
If you want it to continue, let me know.
If there are topics that
you want me to cover,
within that relationship
spectrum, let me know.
I'd love to hear your
thoughts; please share it
down in the comments below.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I really appreciate all your
support, and your love as well.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, guys; I'll see you soon.